now to a shocking political development
out of the state of New York Republican
candidate for governor Lee zeldin is
down to less than two points against
Democratic governor Kathy hokel in the
very liberal state of New York this
could be the biggest political upset uh
this election year in the making one big
reason violent crime totally out of
control all over New York State Kathy
hoco doesn't seem to care she continues
with defund dismantle no bail laws and
of course she wants to have a listening
tour about guns instead and we have
lacks prosecution for the state's uh
repeat offenders in spite of rising
crime all over the state she didn't seem
to care when her opponent was viciously
attacked on stage by a man with a weapon
that could have killed him and by the
way refused to provide requests at State
security and then by the way on Sunday
two people were shot right outside of
Lee zeldon's Long Island home and an
apparent gang hit while his twin
daughters were home one of the victims
was found under zeldin's porch another
in the bushes his bushes here with more
New York gubernatorial candidate Lee
zeldon first wow this is two attacks at
once I would think the governor would
rightly provide you security number two
I'm glad you're okay is there any
evidence that all this could be
connected to politics or do you believe
the analysis of others that this is
likely gang-related and not not related
politically at all to you
Suffolk County Law Enforcement has told
me that this was not related to me it
wasn't a target of my family or my home
I don't have information to rebut what
the Suffolk County Law Enforcement has
told me so I'm going with what they told
me for now
how did New York how did the the crime
in New York get so out of control and
why does the governor refuse to change
course and do you believe that you can
win the state of New York are these
polls now really showing this is a real
race
I'm not in this race to come in second
I'm all in I'm over 18 months into this
race campaigning all throughout this
entire State one of the reasons why I
got into the race was because of these
pro-criminal laws that have been getting
passed out of Albany from Castle's bail
to less is more releasing people early
from prison the halt act which has
resulted in our correctional officers
and other prison staff being assaulted
more since the April 1st implementation
we've seen it with District Attorneys
like Alvin Bragg refusing to enforce the
law the defund movement targeting our
law enforcement they're attacking
qualified immunity for law enforcement
in New York City they want to do it next
Statewide I believe that Albany needs to
break this one-party rule have a balance
of power start unapologetically backing
our men and women in law enforcement
again giving judges discretion away
dangerousness and by the way utilizing
the Constitutional Authority and I would
say constitutional duty of the governor
to remove a district attorney who
refuses to enforce the law and that's
what that's why I say my first action
the first day I'm in office is turning
to the Manhattan D.A Albert Bragg to let
him know he's being fired this will be
the political earthquake this election
year if you win that race and you're
right in the middle of it wow I can't
believe how close it is I'm glad your
family is safe Congressman thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else